we're on problem
205.
in the table above what is the number of
green marbles in jar are okay so they
let's see they give us a table
see they have
jars jar
p
q
and r
and they say number of red
number of red
they say is x
y
and x
and then they tell us the number of
green
number of green is
y
z
and
z and then they tell us the total
total
is
and
160 and they say in the table above what
is the number of green marbles and jars
so green marbles in jar so we need to
solve for
z
so
what we have here is three variables
and we have three unknowns and we
actually have three equations because we
know that the red plus the green
is equal to the total
for any one of the jars right y plus z
is equal to 120 and x plus z
is equal to
160.
so let's just try to solve this equation
so let's let's try to
get everything i don't know what do we
want to cancel out first
what what happens if we subtract that
equation from this one so let me rewrite
that one over so that's x
plus y
is equal to
80.
i just rewrote that column up down here
now if we were to subtract this from
that or let's just multiply it by
negative 1. so minus x minus y minus 80.
and now let's just add them we get 0
plus z minus y so we get z
minus y is equal to what's 160 minus 80.
well that's just 80
right
and now this is interesting we have z
minus y equals 80 and z plus y is equal
to 120. so i think we're pretty close so
let's write that so we could write this
equation i'll write it in yellow
z
plus y i just switched the order is
equal to
120. and i'm in the back of my mind i'm
like well i have to do is figure out z
so i can figure out z as fast as
possible all the better
add these two equations 2z
plus 0 is equal to 240
z is equal to 120 and that's the number
of green marbles
in jar are 120 and that is not one of
the choices
not one of the choices so where did i
make a mistake
i often make a mistake right near the
end
let's see
x plus z
all right let me see x plus y is equal
to 80
y plus c is equal to 120 x plus z is
equal to 160 fair enough
now i took
this equation and i took this one and i
multiplied by negative 1 and put it here
minus x minus y is equal to minus 80.
then i added these two so you get the
x's cancel out you're left with z minus
y
is equal to 80.
fair enough
z minus y is equal to 80. and then this
equation says
y plus z is equal to 120 oh i see my
mistake
all right this is you see i made it
right at the end z minus y is equal to
80 z plus y is equal to 120.
80 plus 120 is not 240.
80 plus 120 is 200 so 2z is equal to 200
z is equal to 100. boneheaded mistake
so the answer is 100 d
next question
question 206.
in the circle above pq well let me draw
the circle above
this is the circle above
let's see in the circle buff pq okay
they draw a diameter let me draw a
diameter as well
so i want to be accurate
so that's
a diameter
and they label this as o
and r
and they say p q so they have this other
line up here that is parallel
to the diameter so let me draw it up
here
so maybe it looks something like this
that's parallel
and they call this point p
this point q and then they have another
line that says 35 degree angles let me
see if i can draw that
they have a line that goes from here to
here
and they tell us that this angle right
here is 35 degrees
fair enough in the circle above
pq is parallel to diameter or
and has length
and or has length 18.
or has length 18.
what is the length
of minor arc pq
fascinating
so they want to know
what
this is right
so we know we can figure out the
circumference of this circle right the
circumference we know its diameter it's
just going to be the diameter times pi
right so we already know that the
circumference of the circle is 18 pi or
2 times the radius times pi but same
thing
now in order to figure out this arc
length what would be useful and i don't
know yet if i can figure it out is if we
could figure out this angle right here
if we could figure out this angle right
here
we'd be done
then we could easily figure out
we could easily figure out because that
angle as a proportion of 360 would be
the same relative proportion of the
total radius so let's see if we can
figure out what that angle is
just given the information they've
they've given us so this angle here is
going to be 35
35 degrees i feel like i should and how
did i know that well those are opposite
inside angles
right
but let me see what matters is
let me think about it a little bit
if i had
and this is on the circle oh well this
is interesting actually this is
so what is
we should use of information this is a
circle so what is the length of that
right there
well if the if the
diameter is 18 then the radius is 9
right then that length is 9 then this
length is also going to be 9
right
and if that length is 9
oh this is interesting this length is 9
this length is also 9
right
that length also has to be 9 they're
both radiuses of the circle
which tells us that this right here is
kind of an isosceles triangle on its
side right it looks like that
it looks like that where these sides are
equal they're both equal to 9. so this
is a 35 degree angle
then this right here has to be a 35
degree angle as well i know you can't
read it because the base angles of an
isosceles triangle
are are equal right i mean i could
redraw it like this this is an
interesting problem
35 so if we know that length is equal to
that length we know that that angle is
equal to that angle
so then we know
that this angle right here has also got
to be equal to
right
now this is useful
because if this angle is 35 and that
angle is 35 what is this entire angle
what is that entire angle
well that entire angle let me draw it up
here
so that's the pq side
so this is also 35 so this entire angle
right here
is 70 35 plus 35 i'm just kidding i
should have drawn this a lot bigger
so this right here is 70 degrees and how
did i figure it out i figured out this
is 35
because this is an isosceles triangle
and i figured out that this is 35
i figured out that this right here is 35
because it's an it's a in it's an
opposite angle from a transversal
between two parallel lines right because
that line
is parallel to that line
right
so that was all
that was all pretty useful
now
what if we could if there was only a way
to figure out what this angle was
because if we know this angle and this
angle then we know for sure
this angle
well i'm going to use the same argument
this
this line right here this is a
this is a radius of the triangle right
so this side right here is also 9
that side so if we know that this side
is equal to this side right let me draw
the triangle that i'm talking about now
because i think this is an important
problem
so i'm trying to figure out the value of
this upside down triangle
and i'll label it so you know what i'm
talking about
so this is p
this is q and this is the center of the
circle
we just figured out and we know that
this side is nine this side is nine and
we just figured out that this angle
right here is 70
right this was 35 plus another 35
once again isosceles triangle if this
side is equal to that side then this
angle is equal to this angle so this
angle also has to be equal to 70.
and now if we know two angles of a
triangle we know the third this has to
be oh i'm gonna roll i'm not gonna
answer the phone
oh i think it's my wife
she let me i'm gonna call her back right
after this
so what was i doing i lost my train of
thought but oh i was on a roll so if
this angle is 70 degrees this angle is
70 degrees
then this angle has to be what 70 plus
plus x is equal to 180 degrees
140 plus x is equal to 40 degrees
sorry is equal to 180 my brain was
skipping ahead
x is equal to 40 degrees
okay so that angle is 40 degrees this
which is the same thing as that angle
so the length of so let's go back to the
problem we have to figure out what this
arc length is right
so this angle which is 40 degrees
40 degrees over the entire
all the degrees in the circle over 360
is going to be equal to this arc length
let's just call it x
over the circumference of the whole
circle and we know that the
circumference of this whole circle is 18
pi
over 18 pi
so let's see if we can simplify this 40
goes into 360
but that's one-ninth right so this
becomes 1 over 9
right
and then we could cross multiply and get
9x is equal to 18 pi
x is equal to
18 pi divided by 9 is equal to 2 pi
and luckily that's one of the choices
it's choice a
see you in the next video i now have to
call my wife